si la distancia entre el plano a x2 y c
está igualada y el plano que contiene
las líneas esta línea de aquí y esta
otra línea de aquí
estas dos igualdades claramente una
línea es raíz de seis estamos hablando
de la distancia entonces el valor
absoluto de es y bueno vamos a pensar
este problema un poco me dicen que la
distancia entre este plano y el plano
que contiene estas dos líneas rectas
entonces estoy refiriendo a la distancia
entre dos planos que tienen que ser
paralelos es decir dos planos que no se
intersectan porque si los planos se
interceptaran pues la distancia mínima
pues sería cero entonces para hablar de
distancia entre dos planos y que me
digan que raíz de seis me estoy pensando
en que son dos planos paralelos así que
vamos a dibujarlos el primer plano es
este de aquí que por cierto tenemos la
ecuación su ecuación es a x menos 210
más z igual a d por otra parte tenemos a
otro plano que es paralelo me voy a
dibujar a este de aquí este de colgará
azul en el cual habitan dos líneas
así que voy a poner dos líneas una que
va a ser esta de aquí entonces déjenme
tomar un color y llamar a esta línea de
color verde esta va a ser una de mis
líneas que evitan este plano y otra
línea que va a ser esta de camps que
también habitan plano quien se ve como
sean pero sé que las dos viven en este
plano y bueno también sé que la
distancia entre estos dos planos es la
raíz de 6 ahora cómo encuentro el valor
de de y bueno el menú para resolver este
problema lo que se me ocurre es pensar
primero que este plano el plano de azul
tiene que tener una ecuación muy
parecida a este plano de rojo que
tenemos aquí si nosotros encontramos la
ecuación del plano de azul te vas a dar
cuenta que lo único que van a diferir es
en el valor de t porque todos planos de
la misma inclinación y lo único distinto
es por donde pasa cada uno de ellos así
que una vez que tenemos la ecuación del
plano de azul lo que voy a hacer es usar
la fórmula de distancia de un punto a un
plano para que con un punto que viva en
el plano azul yo pueda utilizar todos
los datos que tenga y sacar mi valor de
d
así que lo primero que podemos
es encontrar la ecuación de este plano
de azul que tengo aquí y para esto tengo
dos rectas y bueno estas dos rectas las
voy a utilizar para encontrar puntos en
este plano y entonces yo pueda encontrar
dos vectores en este plano y con esto
trabajar el producto cruz y así me puedo
encontrar un vector normal a este plan a
ver vamos por partes voy a encontrar dos
puntos de esta línea recta que tengo
aquí y para esto lo que voy a hacer es
igualar cada una de estas igualdades a
cero a su vez y entonces si esto es
igual a cero me queda que x tiene que
valer 110 tiene que valer 2
iceta tendría que valer 31 menos 102
menos 203 menos 30 y bueno qué pasa si a
continuación igualó todo esto a 1 pues
me quedaría que x tiene que valer 3
después me quedaría 3 x 1 + 2 me quedan
5 ya tiene que valer 5 porque 5 menos 2
entre 3 es lo mismo que uno y si esto es
igual a 1 se también tendré que quedar 4
3 es decir 77 menos 3 entre 4 me da 1
aquí ya tengo dos puntos que viven en
esta línea recta
si yo consigo otro punto con esta otra
línea recta que no hemos usado entonces
ya voy a poder encontrar dos vectores
que vivan en este plano y bueno a ver
vamos a igualar esto a cero y me
quedaría el punto 2 3 menos 4 es decir
voy a utilizar mi segunda línea recta
para encontrar otro punto para que yo
pueda encontrar sus vectores posición y
después encontrar dos vectores que vivan
en este plano bueno igualando esta cero
me va a quedar el punto 234 este punto
de amarillo este vive en esta línea que
habíamos dicho que era de color magenta
entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí este punto
de aquí un pequeño punto de color
amarillo para que no nos vayamos
perdiendo ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
tomarme dos puntos que viven en esta
línea recta para que cuando yo me fijé
en la diferencia de su vector exposición
pueda encontrar un vector que viva en el
plano voy a definir al vector am como
aquel vector que está en una línea recta
por si te das cuenta estos dos primeros
puntos están en una línea recta por lo
tanto este vector tiene que existir en
esta línea recta y para esto me voy a
tomar la diferencia en 3
valores 3 - 12 que multiplica el vector
canónico y 5 -2 me da 3 que a su vez
multiplica el vector canónico jota y 73
me da 4 que multiplica el vector
canónico cam y aquí ya tengo un vector
que vive en el plano es un vector que
está encima de esta línea recta porque
estos dos puntos vivían en esta línea
recta de verde aquí tengo a mi vector a
y a continuación no voy a tomar la
diferencia de los vectores posición de
otros dos puntos pero ahora tengo que
tomarme un punto que está en la recta de
verde y otro punto que está en la recta
de morado por lo tanto ahora me voy a
tomar un vector que esté también al
plano pero que no esté en ninguna de
estas dos rectas y bueno a este vector
lo voy a definir como ve de que va a ser
bueno me voy a tomar la diferencia entre
las coordenadas y multiplicando por mis
lectores canónicos dos menos uno me da
11 y tres menos dos me da 11 jota y 4
menos tres la edad también acá entonces
ya tengo a otro vector que también vive
en este plano y es el vector y mascota
de máscara y este vector va de un punto
debilidad de verde
otro punto de mi línea magenta y bueno a
continuación lo que mueve a tomar es el
producto cruz de ahí ve porque el
producto cruz de ahí ve me va a dar un
vector que es normal a estos 2 es decir
con ello voy a obtener un vector normal
al plano que es justo lo que necesito
así que vamos a tomarnos la definición
del producto cruz pongo y jk después los
valores de las componentes de a 2 3 y 4
y después los valores de los componentes
debe es decir 1 1 1 y ahora si dice me
olvidé de estas dos columnas y me queda
tres por una es 3 menos 4 por 13 menos 4
me da menos 1 y menos 1 x el vector y me
da menos y después voy a olvidarme estas
dos columnas pero recuerda que aquí es
menos intercaló el signo o me olvido de
estas dos columnas y me quedan dos por
unas 2 menos
la multiplicación de 4 por 1 recuerda
que no le hacemos caso a esta columna 4
por unas 4 es decir 2 menos 4 del cual
me da menos 2 pero menos por menos me va
a dar más
j y por último camps cada dispositivo
intercala los signos y me queda 2 por 12
menos 32 menos 3 me da menos 1 y esto
multiplicado por el vector canónico que
me da menos campo es decir mi vector
normal este vector que es ortogonal al
plano va a ser mi vector menos y más 2 j
menos acá y perfecto ya tengo un vector
en este plano y ya tengo un vector que
es normal a este plano entonces ya puedo
encontrar la ecuación de este plano si
yo calculo el producto punto con un
vector muy especial recuerdas nosotros
lo primero que hacemos era tomarnos un
punto en este plano así que supongamos
que me tomo un punto aquí pero este
punto cumple la propiedad de que era un
punto cualquiera de este plano por lo
tanto voy a poner que es el punto x 10 z
y de aquí me tomaba su vector posición
después me fijaba en otro punto que si
supiera que estuvieran en plano y
también me tomaba su vector posición y
después me tomaba la diferencia entre
estos dos vectores posición para que me
dieran un vector que existiera en el
plano por ejemplo aquí si me tomo este
vector que va desde el punto de la línea
que estaba
es decir este de aquí a este punto
eficiencia también que me quedaría pues
me quedaría un vector cuyas componentes
son las siguientes x 3 x por el vector
canónico y más de 5 por el vector
canónico jota más z menos 7 por el
vector canónico que aquí ya tengo un
vector cualquiera que existe en este
plano de azul que yo tengo aquí pero
además es un vector muy importante
porque es un vector visto desde una
forma bastante general y bueno lo que yo
tengo que hacer para encontrar la
ecuación de este plano es tomarme el
producto punto del vector n con este
vector que acabo de encontrar es decir
en el punto x menos 3 x y más o menos 5
por jota más z menos 7 por el vector
canónico acá y recuerda que como estos
dos vectores son ortogonales mi producto
punto tiene que ser igual a cero esto
era muy importante para encontrar la
ecuación de un plano y recuerda que
estos dos vectores son ortogonales
porque el vector en esa ley del producto
cruz de dos vectores que están en este
plano lo que me está dando un vector que
es ortogonal al plano y por lo tanto
esto
cero porque el vector que acaba de
construir ese si existe en este plano
del cual quiero sacar la ecuación
entonces me va a quedar menos 1 por x
menos 33 x lo único que hice fue voltear
los signos después 2 porque menos 5 es
lo mismo que dos y menos 10 2 porque
estoy en menos 5 por 2 es menos 10 y
después nos queda menos 1 que multiplica
la componente z menos siete y entonces
hay que cambiar los signos y me queda 7
menos zeta y esto tiene que ser igual a
0 y bueno ahora todos los números los
voy a pasar de un lado de la ecuación y
todo lo que tengan que ver con x y z lo
voy a dejar del otro lado de la ecuación
y me queda menos x más 2 james z esto es
igual a paso el 3 del otro lado con
signo contrario
víctor se vuelve menos 3 después pasó en
menos 10 con signo contrario o dicho de
otra manera agregó 10 de ambos lados y
me queda más 10 y por último paso el 7
del otro lado de la ecuación y me queda
menos 7 y si te das cuenta menos 3 7 10
es lo mismo que 0 - 3 más 10 menos 7 es
lo mismo que 0 por lo tanto me quedan
menos x + 3 menos
de igual a cero y que crees esta ya es
la ecuación de mi plano de azul del cual
era necesario sacar la ecuación de este
plano de azul ya tengo se cuestiona su
ecuación es menos x más 2 y menos zeta
igual a 0 y esto nos dice bastante
porque como estos dos planos son
paralelos quiere decir que tienen la
misma inclinación por lo tanto los
coeficientes de x de jay-z tienen que
ser iguales pero aquí está pasando algo
raro porque si te das cuenta tengo menos
27 y aquí tengo más 2 james z por lo
tanto lo que ves es multiplicar toda
esta ecuación x menos 1 y que me va a
quedar pues multiplicar por menos 1
solamente es cambiar los signos x menos
2 en maceta igual a 0 lo único que estoy
haciendo es multiplicando ambos lados de
la ecuación por menos 1 y entonces esta
ecuación ya se parece mucho más a la
ecuación que yo tenía del plano de rojo
y además me está dando de una manera
explícita el valor de amd porque si
estos dos planos son paralelos los
coeficientes tienen que ser los mismos
el menos 2 day está al lado del -2 de y
el z tiene como coeficiente 1 también
aquí se trataría como coeficiente 1 y
por lo tanto x aquí tiene con
coeficiente 1 y aquí tiene como fin
a am lo que quiere decir que tienes que
ser forzosamente uno entonces este plano
de rojo su ecuación no quedaría x menos
2 maceta igual a de una vez que encontré
la ecuación del plano de azul ya
encontrar cuánto vale a es muy sencillo
porque recuerda que los coeficientes
tienen que ser iguales pero bueno no
vamos tras el valor de amd lo que
queremos es saber cuánto es el valor del
valor absoluto de de esa es realmente
nuestra pregunta de este problema y
bueno para esto lo que voy a hacer es
tomarme un punto en este plano aquí
tengo varios ejemplos de puntos en este
plano y no voy a fijar en la distancia
de este punto a este plano rojo que
tengo aquí y para esto voy a utilizar la
fórmula de la distancia me voy a fijar
en la distancia que hay de un punto en
este plano al plano de rojo para que yo
sepa cuál es el valor de de y la idea es
bastante sencilla es decir voy a buscar
esta distancia de kim y bueno para esto
lo que quiero recordar es cuál es la
fórmula de la distancia además tome en
cuenta que aquí nos dan un dato muy
importante nos dan que la distancia es
lo mismo que la raíz de 6 pero bueno
ahorita utilizo eso lo que quiero
fijarme es que la fórmula de la
distancia
tomamos esta ecuación de tu plano y en
esta ecuación de tu plano lo que vas a
hacer es sustituir este punto el 123 en
sus respectivos valores de x y z de la
ecuación de tu plano y después restar el
valor de de que recuerda que es justo
atrás lo que vamos tras el valor
absoluto de de ojo me estoy tomando este
punto de aquí y entonces me queda x que
vale uno menos dos veces siempre oye
vale dos entonces menos cuatro y después
a esto hay que agregarle z pero se está
vale tres más tres y después ponemos
menos de que de hecho es esta de que
tengo aquí nuestra fórmula de la
distancia decía que hay que pasar a ésta
desde el otro lado restando y todo esto
hay que dividirlo entre la raíz cuadrada
de a cuadrada más b cuadrada más de
cuadrada pero a veces son los
coeficientes que están al lado de la x y
z es decir entre la raíz cuadrada de 1
al cuadrado menos 2 al cuadrado me da
cuatro entonces es uno más cuatro y
después a esto hay que sumarle uno
1 al cuadrado y bueno esto ya lo podemos
simplificar un poco 1 - 4 3 se cancela
todo esto me da 0 entonces esto se va y
me queda simple y sencillamente la parte
de arriba menos de mientras que en la
parte de abajo me queda uno más cuatro
más uno lo cual me da 6 es la raíz
cuadrada de 6 pero ojo aquí es donde voy
a utilizar el último dato que me dan en
el problema el problema dice que la
distancia que hay de un plano a otro es
la raíz cuadrada de 6 es decir esta
distancia de aquí es lo mismo que la
raíz cuadrada de 6 y bueno creo que todo
está bastante a su lado por lo tanto
sería bastante bueno ponerlo con otro
color este dato que me dan esta raíz de
6 que es la distancia que hay de un
plano a otro es justo esta distancia que
estoy buscando es decir la distancia del
punto al plano y bueno de aquí ya puedo
despejar a menos de porque que me queda
si yo multiplico ambos lados por raíz de
6 me queda que 6 es igual a menos de
aunque t es igual a menos 6 y ojo no me
están pidiendo el valor de de me están
pidiendo el valor absoluto de d es decir
lo único que tengo que hacer es sacar
valor absoluto de ambos lados
esta igualdad pero ya casi estoy
acabando este problema esta de que no
hay que confundir con la de distancia lo
que me está diciendo es justo donde está
el otro plano y bueno para esto entonces
tengo que sacar el valor absoluto de de
que es lo mismo que el valor absoluto de
menos 6 que es 6 y ya con esto encontré
la solución de este problema que por
cierto nos piden el valor absoluto
porque si te es positivo entonces este
plano está arriba del plano de azul y si
te es negativo entonces este plano de
naranja está abajo del plano de azul y
bueno espero que hayas encontrado todo
esto bastante útil